[Applaudissements]
on va se régaler avec toutes les images
de luigi merci d'être là mon luigi et
d'un début de saison exceptionnel
patrick chan frais luigi c'est vraiment
de trouvailles beaucoup mais vraiment il
ya trois nouveaux rené malleville luigi
et patrick sont frais cherchez l'erreur
c'est l'anniversaire de la personne voit
ça va c'est bon bah pas non plus c'est
pas j'avais un petit cadeau je garde
pour moi
en attendant hier soir j'étais avec ma
grand-mère et grosse ambiance parce que
qu'est-ce qui regardent le soir m'a mis
sa chaîne préférée public sénat ah ouais
sympa ça je ne peux pas ne pas mâcher
chier à je dirais une certaine colère ou
m'a dit certaines désapprobation je vais
prévenu grosse ambiance et pendant ce
temps là sur ces 8 300 kg
peyreleau mamie aller vite on est pro 5
et pour le doliprane adultes c'est un
drame
enfin joué trois fois par jour très bien
et pendant ce temps là sur ces 8
ma grand-mère quatre ans la télécommande
pour zapper sur bfm business
microsoft 1 % advanced micro device mais
c'est pas de gaffe à mais c'est dans la
tête que j en hausse de 4%
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
pendant ce temps là sur ces 8 et u la
relève
[Applaudissements]
ils avaient fait de leur mieux avant
quand je vois un très bon retour de
cette émission merci à vous et bravo à
tous ceux qui ont participé
voilà où les pas tous les citer mais
merci parce que il n'y fait le succès de
cette émission tout cas ça fait du bien
ça ce week-end regarder le foot sur
canal et à la mi temps j'étais obligé
d'appuyer sur stop pourquoi qui s'est
passé vous allez voir son couloir qui
vont montrer il nous reste quelques
instants à aller on est en place tout ça
parle football tranquillement mais
attendez stop
regardez ce qui se passe derrière
apparemment il y en a qui maîtrisent pas
de bouffe le scooter qui va bien en
revanche au scooter injoignable
j'étais en train de regarder le
téléshopping pour vous acheter un petit
cadeau d'anniversaire présente tout ça
voilà et un moment marion vrai qu'elle
fait et le métro de sophie costumes jean
michel mr merci c'est vous c'est vous
fait date et les peurs un petit peu de
temps il faut que les grosses nations
dont je regarde tes shopping pour votre
cadeau anniversaire et marié ange qu'est
ce qui est fait propose un produit
révolutionnaire vous connaissez le livre
traîne ce culte excusez-moi aux
puncheurs accord de séparation qui colle
ce qu'ils me disent tu abrutis on les
entend par l'antenne on veut pas les
entendre nulle part l'entente du jamais
vu jamais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cadeau le liechtenstein est ce que c'est
mais non c'est quoi vous allez voir
c'est un vrai truc c'est un vrai truc
qui existe un jeu vous combien vous
allez voir quand je début je me suis dit
ah je suis à deux doigts de lui offrir
ça et vous allez pouvoir raffermir
dessinée tout l'ovale du visage ne passe
à sa bouche fermée où pâturent oubliez
pas de bistouri pas d'un chèque région
rien de tout ça c'était fini et c'est
hyper naturel
regardez d'ailleurs les transformations
incroyable sur ces jeunes femmes et ça
c'est aussi ce même segment
[Applaudissements]
j'adore la semaine dernière je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez je vous parlais de
l'émission club luminy sur france 4 bons
toi nous avez fait la démo de ses
talents de peintre vous souvenez
regarder le futur
on sait qu'on va découvrir avec antoine
il va feindre avec les bras avec les
bras ah là là mais c'est pas si mal à
laisser pas mal en fait
alors figurez vous qu antoine double
casquette il est aussi sosie de chat
antoine bac + 5 en école de journalisme
nous rappelle qu'il faut bien bouffer
dans la vie un web et antoine attendait
c'est quoi cette boîte là ils vont quand
même pas demandé antoine d'aller dans la
boîte se serait amusé pourquoi en annexe
crise
incroyable ouh là là ou là ces voix-là
attendus selon sonore way et antoine
aubin toi les having the sun
leur schéma si 20 des cas des gens
m'adorent de pauvres antoine on emboîte
le pas toute l'équipe en embrassant des
bisous partout et cyril je vous ai dit
en début d'émission de la musique et le
propos alors je voulais raconter comme
l'histoire d'un mec avec moi que ce
n'est pas le cas de combat et une la
plus grande arnaque lui l'histoire
également je crois que c'est lui qui
vous paye lee julie pourquoi la sortie
jean michel mr et sophie cost il m'a dit
c'est pour le tractopelle parce qu'il va
avoir un grand jeu avec un tractopelle
avec difool dans un an dans un instant
et je dis mais c'est pas tout de suite
ces inventeurs disent tu pourrais plus
les maîtres pendant la pub oui mais non
c'est bien de tizé avant tu sais quoi
baptisé quoi petit cadeau voilà il ya
une star qui a tenu absolument à vous
laisser un message pour votre
anniversaire est une vraie star
j'en avais j'ai eu un cadeau de noël
juste un cadeau de ouf et là aussi vous
allez voir c'est une star c'est jason
newsted c'est une vraie ça je peux pas
vous dire exactement petit c'est mais
pour laisser le suspense je vous donnais
les trois premières lettres de son
prénom
vas-y gad way essais mais y'a quoi
d'autre aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui juste le message pour cyril
pour son anniversaire faux pas de tout
client pourquoi me quel message vidéo
c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui
ben alors je peux l'appeler lui laissé
un texto tu viens fin de cette vidéo et
qui fut sa tante hélène qu'est-ce que ça
va être content nous il mais on n'a pas
besoin de diffuser je l'appelle c'est
mon pote
wimbee fouet c'est bien je suis fait un
petit truc pour son émission ça va
l'aider je sais pas c'est pas c'est pas
au loup non c'est très sympa c'est très
sympa ça aurait d'arcade au tuc rond
mais oui je suis pour jouer les
anniversaires stérile bah oui c'est son
anniversaire
ok je me suis je fais tout de suite
cyril comme tu sais les artistes on n'a
pas grand chose à faire en ce moment et
mon manager m'a dit que c'était ça mon
truc de la journée donc je les
anniversaires mon frère je t'aime je
vois des regards je lève c'est vraiment
moi la bombe c'est vraiment pour moi son
meilleur ami vraiment scholem et à
chaque fois qu'on a un petit coup de mou
un truc il m'appelle toujours et il
adore et regardent l'émission tous les
soirs c'est vraiment mon frère je le
sors et je pense avoir une cale hakim al
hicha il me met la pression le conte
[Applaudissements]